how are you Scott good morning dad I'm
great that misery stuff we're done it's
over over yep done yep was that the
greatest night of your life and what it
was exactly that father's day with my
son in Cleveland Ohio watching LeBron
and the Cavaliers and the 52 year
drought I'm not sure anything's in
second place anymore how would you
describe your emotions and those around
you going into Game seven well you know
going into Game seven in it when it
comes to emotions I I speak only for me
it was really hard to summon anything
resembling confidence yeah it's it's uh
maybe says more about me in cleveland or
certainly about the Cavaliers but uh
histories history Vegas is Vegas and I'd
be lying if I told you I thought it was
gonna add the way it says I did not know
I did not feel confident did ESPN film
the ending there and the reaction of
Cleveland fans and editor at it are you
going to add it to the believe Linda
Miller absolutely I knew it was it was
again the longest shots but it happened
and ESPN films was there and and you're
exactly right and and not knowing the
mothership that that that they will be
done by two I don't know I mean it was
awesome it really was i you know you
know you don't want to turn the more
superlatives you used let the less
credibility well you talk about miracles
yes sir yeah there will be an epilogue
that Leland what about emotions empty
realize you'd want to championship I I
you know I I cry at the drop anything a
lifetime would complete when sports fan
hood has prepared me for defeat but also
for sadness that comes with it the the
overwhelming emotion the joy again it
all sounds like a greeting card but it
transcended all of the sadness in a way
that movie you know beyond peers and
then there was one large guy you know it
is it sa 660 300 300
he pops whoo man dad I was worried for
my lower back on 63 years old but I'm
saying men were literally hugging each
other and we big and again uh you know
it's sports it's only sports it's not
really the ego it was everything I ever
could have dreamed of and more it was
awesome where was where were you
watching it in Cleveland well you know
the the the two official watch parties I
think it's a buying 30,000 sold out in
second one so we found a place Wild
Eagle saloon I don't think anyone
progressed they tried to keep
progressive field open this tribe played
yesterday and one by the way sweeping
the White Sox the first place Cleveland
Indians city of champions I don't know a
easy scunt using you know that again
easy you say if I'm not going to get
carried away this morning brother wet
wet well it did it let's just kick what
Cavaliers not your first place Cleveland
but I did hear the start I did hear this
last night if you're a Cleveland Browns
fan are you celebrating this
championship the same way well I don't
know too many either or fans it's
certainly a football town but but but
you have so much heartache with football
just this it's uh I i I'm telling it's
over for me I can only speak for me but
I was 12 years old when the grounds one
and i love the brown part of it for me
by the waist at the NFL let them leave
art modell I will always show those the
internally condemned for me but the NFL
let that happen the only votes to keep
the Browns in Cleveland were from the
Rooney family and and Wilson in Buffalo
and I'll never not love them for that
but you know the NFL was dead to me and
these new brows did nothing but it's
disgraced so for anywhere in Cleveland
was holding out somehow it still feels
they get to whine about the driver art
sister those are footnotes now to me
those are footnotes he's Scott Raab the
Cleveland Fan author writer he was the
producer for the 30 for 30 documentary
believed land you did write the [ __ ] of
Akron welder now be a sequel yes sir and
we
and we've got the perfect title too and
that is you're welcome Cleveland will
LeBron take part in this book oh that's
doubtful you know it I sold my soul to
the devil i really did I make you know
but but that's the weird thing when i
think about it i condemned a young man
to help for the crime of making a
decision he felt was in his best
interest professionally and personally I
for the crime of not being Moses and
leading my tribe for the promised land I
can sign him to hell then he comes back
and and and that just comes back but
says I'm roses I feel a mission that I
mean am i embarrassed and ashamed I I
won't deny there some of that but you're
welcome Cleveland fact I don't know look
I'm not quite LeBron's I bought in
Cleveland sports history is what now
well Jim Brown and LeBron and yeah I
would have to go back before my time
there's a 48 indians with lou boudreau
and Satchel Paige you know there's some
some great moments and I know that
because there were so few but LeBron it
if there's Rushmore there there's only
Jim Brown and LeBron James and maybe
Jesse Owens yeah you know who's again
one of the greatest athletes Northeast
Ohio ever produced but seriously LeBron
forever in it you know not to broaden
the question to ridiculousness but as
I've heard over and over here from a lot
of people the legacy there yeah i think
is also again as hypocritical as it
sounds for guy who wrote the horror of
Akron I never denied in that book or
ever this was the greatest basket but
not today I'm not going to say Michael
wasn't the greatest NBA player of all
time I'm just saying for the range of
skill for the ability to dominate to do
what we've seen him do you know whether
you're an analytic sky whether you're an
eyeball guy III don't know what more
this guy has to do to prove that he
belongs in the conversation even and
I've any one of places kopi ahead of him
because of counting the rings there's no
argument I could make their to convince
that person but you know for me his
as a Cleveland I I grew up in Cleveland
he's from northeast ohio there's no
question him and Jim Brown if LeBron
does not finish his NBA career in
Cleveland finish that sentence I'm good
if he has left for miami and having one
ring for Cleveland I certainly no would
have wrote a book like mine we would
have had a tear in our I but with it
would have had nothing but love in our
hearts we are speaking for me if if he
decides to leave he has he has done
something miraculous I'm saying
considering the opposition considering
the three two one hole to the 73 and
nine my goodness my goodness I that guy
gets to do whatever he was what are you
going to do with yourself the rest of
the day I'm writing a book I got three
chapters I gotta get going on the book
but you know I just got home we took a
6am flight out of Cleveland landed in
newark drop my kid off at school is that
a history test at 10 and I want to sit
with my wife a while maybe shed a few
more tears good for you good luck on the
sequel and stay in touch thank you Scott
thank you that's a scott ram he wrote
the horror of akron former Esquire
writer and producer in the 30 for 30
documentary believe land the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience